les noms des victimes s'efface peu à peu
alfonso paul joseph jean amédée ou
encore serge ils étaient 10 la plupart
âgés entre 21 et 24 ans des résistants
installés dans la ferme de limmat sur
les hauteurs de signes
s'ils voient qu'il ya eu des massacres
comme signe fait savoir ces hauts lieux
de la résistance nous avons sur sign 8
un marché qui a eu à trois gros matchs
comme gros maquis et il y en a des tués
à droite et à gauche parce qu'ils
soignent et les maquisards objet d'une
dénonciation le 2 janvier 1944 on cercle
et par les nazis ils seront capturés et
fusillé sur place un massacre
aujourd'hui commémorer défilé dans les
rues du village
dépôt de gerbe pour ne pas oublier ces
civils tombés au combat
parmi eux des français mais aussi des
étrangers c'était des frères d'armes et
des frères d'armes pourquoi pour lutter
contre une idéologie mortifère qui
s'appelait le nazisme et le fascisme qui
justement étaient les vecteurs d'un
nationalisme exacerbé juste le contraire
de ce que représente la résistance
c'est-à-dire cette fraternité
internationale
c'est ça le beau message de la
résistance surtout en ce moment
72 ans après ce drame résonne encore
comme une énième leçon de l'histoire
nous rappelons que le combat continue
contre les idéologie mortifère et les
extrémismes en tout genre
[Musique]